what I like most about modern warfare
playing the beta is that it feels
fundamentally different and it's more of
my speed where it feels a lot more
tactical and it strips away a lot of the
extraneous elements that I didn't
necessarily mess with in previous Call
of Duty's but it makes so many different
small changes that making you play a
little bit more tactical and in that
regard it it's different enough for me
to feel like I'll do he's doing
something fundamentally different I
really like how much modern warfare
feels like a return to original modern
warfare with the killstreaks nvg came
from the first one there's these throw
backs that help somebody like me who's
been sort of a lapsed Call of Duty
player you know I've played a couple of
the recent multi players but in general
I kind of like went away from this
series and this feels like a reason to
come back to it one of the things that
was really interesting is I think we all
came to like this beta from really
different reasons
like I love ground war but could not
stand gun fight and you felt like a
hundred percent the opposite but it
we're all from different you know
different backgrounds in gaming and we
all found something in this beta that we
really liked and could could stick with
I'm coming to it from a perspective as
someone who played a lot of competitive
Counter Strike I'm playing modern
warfare like that now where I'm checking
corners and I'm going into rooms where
I'm only peeking in certain angles so I
like life I know someone's there I'll be
able to shoot them and if not if no
one's area I can move on it moves much
slower and everything that they've built
around the systems even like small
changes support that style of play
whether it's the way you ATS movement
speed the way you peek around corners or
the way the different attachments give
you different advantages in certain
styles of play all these small changes
kind of feed into that style of game and
I think that actually speaks to it
almost like a design philosophy of the
whole game is that each of those little
things address something else in the
game itself like
for a long time we wanted like just the
quality of life benefit of being able to
edit our loadouts during during a match
and as much as that's sort of a
something I've always wanted to be able
to do there's even purpose to it in this
game where you know when you drop new a
match of like MVG and realize like I
dropped in when I realized that the
scope that I had on my rifle was like
messing up my sight picture when I go to
ATS and I could just on the next life
pull the scope off and then jump into
the next phase of the match ready to go
I really appreciate that this is now
it's back to being a thinking man's game
I don't the call of duty was ever like a
thinking man's game but it started
moving that way with specialists in
black ops 4 and now I really have to
think about what I'm doing in each match
there's so much preparation you can do
in your loadout section for each mode so
I you know you can have a you can have
an nvg loadout but that loadout might
not work in the next round of ground war
where all of a sudden you're looking at
like much longer sightlines and you're
contesting with tons more players
running through a door so you can't you
know you might feel grabbed your loadout
with your LMG and your claim and your
double claymores and like there's just
so much to think about in between rounds
and modes in this game that's what is
making this kind of different than
previous ones I like realism mode a lot
I play usually historically a lot of
hardcore and I think in recent years
hardcore has become kind of just
obnoxiously wrote in the franchise you
know the the time to kill is so low that
you know you just an errant shot in the
foot take somebody out and it just it
feels like a different game just because
time to kill doesn't feel right but with
realism what I think is interesting is
that it take it strips so much down the
removal
feedback that you don't get hit markers
that you don't have a feed that tells
you that you got a kill that you don't
know yeah you know you just you see
somebody in a doorway off in the
distance and you take some shots and
yeah I don't know yeah there are a lot
of times playing realism mode where I
have a few shots from someone who was
like off in the distance off of the
bushes at did I get the kill or not it's
sort of like how cyberattack feels like
it brings the best things out of out of
like you know demolition or search and
destroy that realism kind of takes some
of the best things out of hardcore and
makes it like kind of a more fun mode
like it doesn't have like friendly fire
you can't kill your own teammates
they're still healing you know it's not
like fully hardcore but those tweaks
that they made make it kind of more
interesting and more fun alternative to
like the regular mode
my favorite mode was cyberattack
it plays similarly to demolition modes
where one team has to get a bomb or
something and then plants it on the
other team's objective but it's
different enough in the sense that you
know you play it differently because you
can revive teams that's a huge thing and
I was playing a lot of cyber tech
matches where it was maybe 1v1 and that
plays a lot different than if I revived
the teammate and now it's 2v1 the
tactics change on the fly and you in the
mode you have two minutes to revive any
teammate that gets down but you know
I've seen matches shift from 2v to tall
sentence 5v2 yeah viable read yeah and
they even got back to like a one person
died and they revive someone else and
now it's a 4v4 and we're back to square
one it's the that element shifts the
dynamics so much in that mode and I like
playing those modes where you have one
life to live but now it's like I have
like if I if I die early in the round
you know I there's a chance that I might
come back and still play a role in this
so it kind of alleviates the
disappointment of dying early in those
heads and modes even though I like those
style of modes kind of goes back to what
drew me to counter-strike but adding
that element of being with revived
teammates play such a such a huge role
it's a lot more exciting in that sense
as much as I like the competitive
aspects of this game that remind me of
competitive counter-strike cross-play is
another thing to think about I mean I
know that you can tie yourself to
certain control schemes like I can only
say that I only want to play against
other players who are using controller
this is a I played a lot of this beta on
PC and when I was playing against
console players man I was I was like
wrecking fools it's it's it's enough I
think it's an unfair advantage now a
very good console player can keep up
with probably an average PC player I
would call myself maybe an average PC
player in the grand scheme of things but
man the way in which you can snipe and
check corners it's especially in modes
like gunfight where it moves so fast and
if I can just like with my mouse around
the check two corners in like a split
second as opposed to okay I'm gonna
check this corner and then that corner
even though my
tivity is really high on controller that
is such an important aspect to some of
these moe it's like maybe it doesn't
matter as much like as you expand the
scale of the mode like ground war I mean
maybe it won't matter as much unless
you're in certain situations but man if
you're playing like an objective based
mode where you know that everything's in
front of you or the enemies are coming
in front of you then you know I can I
can look it I can check those corners
man real fast I can get shots off in a
specific spot real fast or track enemies
who are sprinting very easily as opposed
to playing with a controller now if
you're playing TDM where you're
constantly spawning in different spots
and it's about you know can I ABS faster
than this guy who's also sprinting where
it's a lot more chaotic maybe the the
bar is a little bit more even in that
sense but man and those these objective
based modes or smaller fast-paced modes
I don't think you want to enable cross
play if you're a console player five
routes down so ground war man I just
felt like I was playing really good like
early battlefield 3 game you know it's
flying around Road killing people in
helicopters or the snipers we're
stealing my helicopters all over again
rolling around in tanks like dominating
upper Ridge lines just fantastic
vertical spaces it feels so good to have
just feels like a battlefield style game
that just wants it that that wants to
like get into this space and a Call of
Duty proved in black ops four that they
could do big maps and they could do
vehicles and it's exciting to see them
putting it all together now also like a
lot of the problems with the core modes
like spawn flipping which I think we all
had problems with where you're running
across the map and something you're
getting shot in the back without knowing
where somebody came from you know this
had good deployment zones and those
deployment zones
we're advantageous to those teams so you
didn't get spawn trapped like they they
really understand how these these medium
to large-sized maps should work and just
create so many like fantastic angles and
spaces for you to play in I will have to
disagree with that
to an extent I may be I just didn't have
a good experience with ground
or maybe I just need to get good but I
do feel that the way ecology D plays and
the sort of maps of the map that they
offered you and the style of play it
didn't work there was at capture points
there are just too many ways in which
you can get killed I know and that's
part of like the danger of going to or
holding down a capture point but it was
it was just it to a point where is them
felt nonsensical and I'm just getting
shot from all kinds of different
directions and I don't it there are
other elements of it like like spawning
where you can spawn on multiple
teammates as they are on the map as long
as they're not tied they're not in the
middle of a firefight you could spawn on
them there were times when I'm like 1v1
in a sniping kind of firefight with
someone else on the other team and then
I'm watching them right there and I see
someone dropped on spawn right on them I
see two more people spawn on them and
it's like I had that it's like fruit
flies out there and really hops out here
and they all like loaded out with
snipers because you can do that sort of
this one there and I'm gonna sniper
rifle now it's like oh now I'm fighting
against five different snipers exactly I
I love that they have that they've
embraced the concept of danger spawning
that like if you're if your teammate is
in a fight you can't spawn there that
was something that you know eventually
battlefield had and it works great but
it's definitely an issue of
implementation you know you guys both
bring up a good point and I think either
they're pulling in people from a lot of
different places and balancing their
systems per mode is definitely important
so for example I think big team battle
as much as I love it it's where kill
streaks fall apart and score streaks
make more sense so for example you would
feel like there was more of a purpose of
dying repeatedly on an objective or
holding it if you were racking up a
score streak over time but because it's
kill streaks you doing that becomes can
become pointless or like you playing as
a support role so like shooting down
UAVs which is super important or like
supplying teammates with stuff you're
not getting rewarded for support actions
which is where I think score streaks
would make a little bit more sense in
some of these these modes one thing you
did mention was kill streaks and
scorestreaks for killstreaks I just
don't think they work for for ground war
it's just too much man because there's
so many different players that can rack
up those kills and necessary to unlock
the kill streaks on there so you have
cruise missiles flying way too often I
mean is there a moment that a UAV isn't
flying yeah a muzzle just like I have
ever put everyone on the damn map so you
can see where everyone is because the
rate at which you rack up kill streaks
and you have so many players and doing
that it's like oh that's too much I
don't know they may change something in
the future leading up to launch to kind
of alleviate that sort of thing but I
don't think killstreaks have a place in
ground war
the other interesting thing is I think
this is across all the Moe's apex kind
of shoot our industry what a good
call-out system looks like it's really
hard to not have a call-out system in
this game like they really need to give
players more information about what's
going on in any given time so like when
when there's a spawn flip they need to
call out to players that a spawn flip
this happens you're not suddenly like
just taking fire from behind you don't
know why or maybe a ground war you know
they'd give you bare-bones stuff like go
to this objective go to that objective
there was there so many moments when I
was like ah damn why wish there was a
ping system this game needs a ping
system especially if I'm gonna play
something like ground war what's a lot
larger and it's you know it's tougher to
for players to either communicate or
figure out on their own about where
players are going if they're moving
across like the edge of the map and
trying to flank you from behind or take
your first spawn point or your first
capture point like I need to be able to
I need a simple system to make that call
out real quick and battlefield is done
with spotting apex legends has it that
has it down right with ping system call
duty needs something like that at least
for ground war
so after this beta you know coming from
counter-strike we're coming from really
like an old-school Call of Duty are you
looking forward to the release you feel
like there's enough there for you at
this point yeah I think so because there
are a lot of different modes that I'd
even get to mention like night vision
mode is is a really cool thing it like
it changes how you play the map even
though it's aged nighttime the way you
80s the way you look around corners when
I need to flip on my night-vision
goggles and take them off is it's an
added element and when I think about
like gunfight and I think about well I
wouldn't be playing a lot of cyberattack
there's just so many different ways in
which you can play this game but what it
boils the reason why all of that works
is because at a fundamental level called
Duty plays how I would how I really
wanted call of duty to always play which
is the more tactical route it's a little
bit slower it's more of a positional
game so checking corners and all that
stuff that's that's kind of that's my
speed and that's what this game is doing
along with all those other modes so it's
probably the most I've been excited
about a Call of Duty game in quite a
long time